consumer behavior has changed and it's
it changed uh permanently uh so
that means that it was not just a short
period of time to cope with kovid
this is now a top priority high priority
for every brand because
the world is moving from offline to
online right
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl an immediate
partnership with c-tech
the world is constantly changing and
this past two years has seen a dramatic
increase in the consumer expectation to
receive products faster and cheaper meet
guy bloch the ceo of bring
guy has nearly 20 years of experience
leading large organizations in the
global enterprise software market
transforming them into highly successful
hyper growth environments he joined
bring after spending six years in senior
leadership roles at splunk including
c-o-o-e-m-e-a
and area vice president of sales after
previously serving in leadership
positions at hp enterprise epilogue and
emblaze the guy has an mba from new york
institute of technology and a bachelor's
of arts from ben gurion university
guy block welcome to 20 minute leaders
i'm so honored to have you here thank
you
thank you michael so good to be here
well the re the real reason i'm thinking
is not just for being here but for the
technology that you're that you're
leading and developing helping
businesses thrive in the era of last
mile deliveries and efficiency and you
know it's not it's no secret that my
generation as well as other generations
we're very impatient and so we'd like to
get our things quickly and and you're
helping us
get exactly that so thank you very very
much guy before we get into bring and
what you're doing there
tell me a little bit a little bit about
your own trajectory you also were an
executive in one of my favorite
companies called splunk which i used
very very frequently as an engineer but
tell me a little bit about your own
career and then we'll dive into the
world of last mile delivery and
optimization and logistics so guy tell
me a little bit about yourself
yeah happy too so so i was born raised
in israel and just after i graduated my
bachelor degree i actually moved to do
my mba in the us in new york
new york institute of technology and one
thing led to another and i stayed there
for 20 years and i came back just five
years ago with a
beautiful family a wife and three kids
and along the journey there i spent all
my time in enterprise software
um working for various companies
startups and
medium-sized companies and the very
large companies like hp software back in
the years
and my last six years before i joined
the spring i actually had
the pleasure to be part of an amazing
and super successful company which is
splunk i joined splunk when we were
still a couple of hundreds of people
and just starting the journey uh just
after the ipo
uh and the the old notion there was how
do we really go and convert the world
um and and really grow in a global
fashion into every region every
territory every country and bring the
the the
the depth and the power of log files and
the log file management uh to companies
uh
you know when i joined uh
splunk i spent a couple of years as
leading the east coast uh for first plan
and at the certain point three years
into my time with the splunk we realized
that international markets have to kick
in in order for us to grow even faster
um and we decided that one of us should
go there and instead of building a proxy
of the company in emea uh it's actually
to to bring the company into emea and uh
and and build ourselves very deep into
this market i was there for close to
three years i moved my family
uh to the region i worked there in
london for
three years i uh had the the pleasure to
work in
you know not just there but almost every
country in europe middle east and africa
and uh what a journey when i left uh
splunk we were 5 000 employees close to
2 billion dollar in revenue oh my god
and
it was just keep they kept on growing
unbelievable so the the tradition and
the pattern of helping other businesses
thrive and
you know it just continues with the
brain and before we get into bring
specifically tell me about the delivery
world and and the last time we spoke was
about two years ago before covet when
deliveries were huge but now they're
like crazy huge so tell me a little bit
about where we're at in you know
approaching 2022 in terms of deliveries
and more
interestingly not just the delivery
itself but how are businesses
adapting to this new world and this new
age of deliveries
well if i summarize it in one word then
it's called
coffee changed the world it changed
all of that for us as consumers as human
beings first
uh and in the time of kovit and we saw
it very quickly as soon as kovitz
started and
uh hit europe before it even hit
america's
uh we realized that this thing is not
going away and during that time we'll
have so many lockdowns as we see today
and even without the lockdowns and
restrictions people will just uh avoid
getting into crowded places
to protect themselves and therefore if
you cannot
leave your house and go get your food
groceries retail merchandise if you
cannot get it uh
from the store then it needs to come
to you
and everything that we envisioned for
the market to happen within uh a few
years and all the way into 2025 it just
happened in few weeks unbelievable and
what we saw is that every consumer out
there
expects their brands
to provide convenient cost-effective
very fast extremely fast and reliable
delivery you do it well they buy from
you you don't do that well they go
somewhere else where they can
they can get your merchandise all the
foods all the goods um
so where they can get it but also get it
at the service that they want uh what we
realized is that
customers want to control this
experience so as a customer you want to
define where how
and when you're going to get your
delivery and as long as you're in
control that's where you're going to uh
to purchase what was interesting is that
what was nice to have before covid and
many companies explored it became a
must-have they created a lot of panic in
the market uh and every brand was
looking for different ways to recover
their revenue stream uh and therefore we
saw a big move uh from the market into
uh uh scaling up and optimizing uh their
last mile and for us the last uh couple
of years were fast and furious that
means a lot on us as a company uh but uh
it was fast and furious and what's more
interesting is that uh even with covet
in some countries um
is fading out or at least is getting to
some somehow a normal state and we see
uh stores opening up and people going
out back to the streets uh still
consumers they get wired now that
everything can get to them when how and
where they want it and therefore uh
while we see less volume in certain
areas of deliveries we still see it's so
much more higher than what it used to be
before in other words consumer behavior
has changed and it's it changed uh
permanently uh so
that means that it was not just a short
period of time to cope with kovid
this is now a high priority a high
priority for every brand because uh the
world is moving from offline to online
right now
why is it so freaking hard i mean
i think most people can think okay okay
yeah sure you want delivery great
there's a bunch of people on motorcycles
they have waze they have google maps
pick up the package bring it to the door
easy why why are you making such a big
fuss about this thing why is it so hard
guy
because it's a physical world this is
not a digital world you're moving
physical assets physical goods you're
talking about dispatchers and drivers
and warehouses and stores and customers
those are real things and to digitize
and connect those things so algorithms
can move them it's not an easy it's not
an easy journey
imagine a brand that did deliveries
before but in the traditional way you
know uh you can buy online get it
standard chipping maybe expedited
shipping
some sort of tracking and visibility
imagine them now moving into shipping
and delivering millions of packages
millions of goods millions of food items
to millions of customers from stores
from warehouses using their fleet their
own drivers using someone else's need
and usually it's not one fleet because
you have crowdsourced the greek economy
you have 3pls you have parcels fedex ups
dhl and do all of that and some is from
warehouse some is from the stores
families promised from distribution
center and then some of that will be
scheduled where you can actually decide
when you want to receive it but farm is
on demand 30 minutes an hour to do all
of that for a brand that is not expert
in technology in logistic technology
and not expert in building logistic
network ouch that that that's hard
that's that's that's very hard and
what's fascinating is that this is where
technology and i think this is one of
the
only areas and i've been in this uh
enterprise software for so many years
this is one of the only areas when
technology
actually meets the real world
and that's hard that that's a big
challenge and when you look around those
that really perfected that are those
that we love buying from them amazon
florida uber
um you know deliver
world here in israel
those are the companies that we love to
buy from why because there are not no
brands there are technology companies
hundreds and billions of dollars are
being spent on building uh technology to
digitize and connect their fulfillment
and delivery network but then there are
also logistic companies they have their
own gig economy they have their own geek
drivers and they have access to millions
of drivers and when you have those two
and connected
you can perfect that every other brand
in the world is just not in that
position i love it okay and that brings
us to to bring so we understand the
consumer change we understand the
difficulty that and the challenge that
this poses
where does brain coming to store
well break is here to give every brand
the alternative to scale up and optimize
so they can act move and play like there
were a marketplace like they were uber
or doordash or delivery or amazon what
does it mean it means technology
technology on one side and uh access to
logistic network so technology
our philosophy is very simple when you
digitize and when you connect every node
every step of your fulfillment and your
delivery network
um your delivery process then the whole
idea of
automation optimization orchestration of
delivery experiences becomes a data
intelligence game
and that's the first thing that we bring
to our customers is a control tower an
orchestration platform that they can
digitize and connect uh their internal
systems if it's the erp and the
e-commerce platform and oms order
management system and inventory
management system to connect with that
be able to receive all the orders into
one place and from that point make a
decision do you want to do buy online
pick up the store do you want to do
curbside where uh
you know a customer will drive by the
store you'll know that they're outside
and the store associate will put it into
the car do you want maybe to deliver to
lockers and then have customers come and
pick it up by the way those three models
of bobby's a curbside lockers there are
those are not just the most efficient uh
uh models for the brands to offer
consumers they also the cleaner the most
sustainable
options because now you don't have uh
carbon emission being produced to ship
items to customers they actually come to
get to get it from lockers and and spend
time there
so that's one but then uh offering
customers the ability to do 30 minute
delivery an hour two hour same day next
day uh allowing them and by the way by
the way not everything
has to be delivered quickly but to have
the option the brand to be in a position
to offer an option for the consumer to
decide if they want to get it in one
hour or two hours the same day next day
or maybe the next week the fact that
they're giving them the option that's
what's compelling that's what makes them
want to buy and then it goes into the
logistics side of it how are you going
to do that and
if you do that only with a single
carrier a couple of carriers your hands
are locked
your hands are tight
uh because uh you need geographic
coverage and you need good time coverage
all right so during lunch time or during
dinner time uh you have less drivers
that demand out there then you need to
expand in order for you to meet the sla
uh for the consumer does it really
does does it really matter if uh your
delivery provider didn't meet the sla
and he paid the brand a penalty
uh
instead of 30 minutes you got to the
customer in 50 minutes it doesn't really
matter so
they need to have wide options wide
variety of options and that's where they
need access to so many fleets out there
there are hundreds and thousands of
regional carriers that want to do those
deliveries that want to service the
brands that their challenge they working
on are very old technology and moving
them into a new technology and then
making them accessible
to every brand it's what we do and then
believe it or not some brands realize
that the most efficient way to really
deliver is to have your own fleet
because if you know that you have a
density of deliveries in certain areas
why would you outsource all of that to
someone else where you can have your
driver do a few deliveries on everyone
and not one delivery per run
100 and that's what we do so we give
them uh a control tower that gives them
the option to offer bulkies curbside and
lockers uh and then using dirt fleet or
someone else's fleet globally nationwide
and globally
offer endless ways endless ways to
deliver and provide options to customers
and in the bottom of that in the bottom
of that there is a big data lake that
contains a lot of data that we create
and they create and when all this data
is in one place uh and it's such a rich
data set uh the amount of insight and
intelligence you can get so you can make
better decision and always find the most
efficient way to deliver and delight
your customers uh provides endless value
for them
if you're looking at
your experience now with brain and
you're observing the way that all these
different players are entering this new
space you're observing all these
business owners and leaders and
businesses coming in and experiencing
deliveries for the first time
what surprised you
what is something about this transition
that you're saying wow i did not expect
it to be like this beyond the fast pace
that kovid
that kobe brought in well what surprises
you as a strategist and as a thinker
they're saying wow
only because i got to experience this at
this scale
did i see the sun this thing that is not
as trivial as i thought it was
uh there are a couple of things that
really surprised me here but first of
all that change in consumer behavior
in a matter of months
if not weeks and now people just got
rewired on how they want to do shopping
and what we used to do it's like it
almost feels like you know go out to do
shopping or pick up food for food from
restaurants or go do two-hour shopping
in the grocery store it almost feels
like ancient time yes
but that's amazing it's only two years
that we're in it and i just flipped my
dad that i love him so much he's more
than 70 years old
but damn he orders food now on walls uh
and to see that changing so fast
it's exciting because we are in a
position to make it happen for the
brands that's one second thing out the
economy move from a traditional way of
doing things to the new way with the
geek economy and offering all those
models to customers it happens so fast
that it's scary to see our brands are
exposed
um and that's a big change
for us it's inspiring because that's our
mission we are here for them we are here
to help each and every one of the brands
scale up and optimize so they can play
in the game so they can bring a gun to a
gun fight and loot the knife to a
gunfight so they can play they can
compete and they can protect their own
brand in the end of the day it's about
their brand and that's very surprising
to see how exposed they become
and the last thing that is very uh
i would say even inspiring
in the end of the day this industry is
all about economy the basics of economy
demand and supply you have more demand
you will have more supply if you have
more demand
and not enough supply uh then prices
will be higher much higher
uh uh sl will not be met customers will
not be delighted if you have more supply
then demand prices will go down it's
it's equilibrium and there is no static
moment it goes up and down on all sides
and uh for the last couple of years we
haven't got to a point where we felt
like it's balanced right
up and down
and it goes back again into what we do
we are democratizing uh um you know this
industry and the fact that we're giving
all of that in the hands of the brands
they can always find that equilibrium
for themselves
um
those are the things that really
inspires
inspire me and i would summarize and say
that you bring it all together the only
way to really uh for the brands to win
uh against the big guys that have
perfected
uh last mile
over a few years 10 20 years the only
way is not to go head to head with them
it's to almost create a coalition an
alliance of all those small guys coming
together doing batching uh uh you know
bringing all the demand together divided
into densities uh be able to collaborate
i know it it seems like uh
aspirational uh kind of uh strategy and
vision but no it's happening today where
instead of one driver deliver for you
that driver on that same run can
actually serve multiple retailers at the
same time um that's a big challenge they
sedate the challenge but the fact that
it's almost like a coalition coming
together creating a joint force to
create alternatives to the marketplaces
that's exciting it's part especially
when you're in the heart of this
guy thank you so much for these 20
minutes they went by so fast i'm so
inspired by the work that you do we
didn't even get to talk about the crazy
announcements that you guys have had
over the over these past couple years
and it's it's really phenomenal
that's old music
incredible
growth and incredible timing amazing
market an amazing problem and at the end
an incredible impact that you're making
on on all those around and so thank you
very much for the time and for the
inspiration last question for you
a few words that you would choose to
describe yourself before i ask anybody
and bring or splunk who is guideblock
who who is he
uh
i i would say uh first of all i think
you can see it this is my demeanor uh
passionate yeah i drive my passion my
purpose is so deep
uh when when i wake up in the morning
it's for that purpose that creates a
passion for me so very passionate i'm
damn determined um
if i see something no matter how hard it
is i will go through every obstacle and
make it happen
and i would say resilient uh you know as
uh you know especially in my position uh
leading a company in the market that
goes through turbulences uh
it takes a lot of resilience uh and
resilience uh for me and from all the
people around around me here in the
brink and i think this is something we
take pride of uh no matter how hard it
is uh we're here for a purpose and we
will make you know fulfill on our vision
on our purpose regardless how hard it is
nothing will stop us
guy thank you so much for these 20
minutes for the inspiration this was
wonderful and best of luck with the
brain and continue making the the huge
huge impact and thank you very very much
thank you michael
[Music]